let me go next - oh you know who I want
to talk to you Aaron the trucker is on
the line from the two one seven and we
haven't heard from Aaron for awhile and
I'm very interested in what's going on
with trucking right now Aaron how are
you yeah I'm alive yeah so let's say
about that um so yeah trucking is doing
fine
the thing about trucking is is this
unlike a lot of things in this country
this is a very resilient industry
between 71% of everything that you buy
is delivered on a truck right I'm glad
that you recognized me
probably called once but anyway um well
we do have a thing that I want to say is
this fair enough yeah um the only thing
I want to say is this I'm not a leftist
I'm an independent and one of the
reasons for that is the less loves - I'm
not saying Joe Biden is a good guy but
the left loves to point to one thing
that Joe Biden said as Joe Biden being a
bad guy which was Joe Biden saying that
he has no empathy for Millennials who
say that it's hard and he said and I
quote if you don't like the way things
are go out and change now the funny
thing is in many senses that's exactly
what the left is done by electing people
like aoc Ilhan Omar Ayanna Presley ro
Connor the lady who just defeated Dale
at NCATS name escapes me at the moment
right but every person on the left seems
to say is that when it came to voting
for Bernie Sanders the less didn't come
out in the numbers that they should have
but yet I've seen so many people on the
Left who refused to vote for Joe Biden
hmm so it is just mind-boggling to me
that it just seems to me like the left
wants to have it both ways they don't
want to go out and actually do what they
need to do to make sure the fight that
that Sanders gets elected but they don't
want to at the same time they don't want
to vote for the person who is actually
likely to make this country slightly
less bad than four more years of Trump
which would be an absolute nightmare I
just I don't well this is a fundamental
philosophical disagreement right
there are people who believe that if
it's not going to be Bernie that Biden
is essentially just as bad as Trump that
Biden needs to do something to earn
their vote or otherwise you're basically
giving a blank check to the DNC and that
they're willing to tolerate four more
years of Trump Trump getting Supreme
Court picks more federal judges falling
four years further behind on climate
change etc there are other people who
say even if Biden is to my right Trump
is way further to my right Biden
supports the green new deal as a
framework Trump laughs at it and got out
of Paris climate Biden's tax plans
better than Trump's Biden will pick
better judges than Trump and you're
gonna do the thing that is the least bad
as you're pointing out now I might I'm
in that latter group there's some people
in my audience who are in that first
group it's a philosophical disagreement
yeah but it's all I'm saying is that
unless the left is really going to get
it together and really figure out what
it is that they want then you can't
complain about whatever happens whatever
the ramifications are four more years of
Donald Trump right right exactly if you
if you participate if you take an action
that helps Trump get reelected and then
you complain about Trump then there is
certainly some some sort of a double
standard there for sure now Aaron just
on the trucking is there like is there
more demand for truckers right now
because of all the people that are
hoarding stuff let's just say the toilet
paper industry is exploding right what I
can't tell you is there's there's been a
there's been a need for truck drivers
for years and the corona virus outbreak
is certainly not helping but what I can
tell you is there have been measures
taken that basically waive the
restriction that we have the regulations
that we have that if you're hauling food
and supplies the grocery stores you can
get them there as soon as you can Wow
that is not keeping skipping sleep even
that sounds dangerous yep it sounds
dangerous
and of course because this is America
likely people who are going to show
what's why that wasn't a good idea yeah
I did that these swords desperately need
these supplies right so they hope that
you people will use common sense I don't
have confidence that they will but that
yes that's what they're doing for it so
let me say this Aaron can you remind me
what it's normally you can't drive more
than how many hours every how many hours
what's the rule yeah the rule is you're
only allowed to drive up to 11 hours a
day and you're only allowed at 14 hours
from the time you go on duty to do that
okay got it so let me ask you this what
do you think is a safe upper limit for
if the if those restrictions were gone
and you were allowed to drive more how
far would you push it that you believe
is still safe well for me personally
because I can only speak for myself I
could probably drive 13 14 maybe 15
hours not straight of course with double
breaks in between but yeah yeah probably
somewhere more than 12 hours easily yeah
and are you using any you know like
caffeine or anything else when you if
you were to do such a long day no no
okay all right all right
Aaron we'll listen I appreciate you
calling in stay safe out there okay you
too thanks for putting so much emphasis
on me all right
we're following trucking very very
closely all right Aaron thank you very
much don't hang up if you're holding
we're gonna take a quick break and then
we'll go right back to the phones after
this don't hang up if you are holding
right now one of our sponsors is privacy
calm they're giving you five dollars
when you sign up for their completely
free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman I've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up anytime you
buy something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to twelve of these virtual
credit cards a month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them any time you want so
when you do this it means you're not
going to be charged when you don't want
to be because you can destroy the
virtual card number right after using it
which for instance I love using free
trials because I know I won't be charged
when the trial is over if I use a
virtual credit card number you're
keeping your identity private by not
telling companies who you are you're
keeping your bank or credit card info
protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free there's no
catch whatsoever but if you want privacy
also offers a $10 a month plan that
gives you one percent cashback and lets
you create 36 credit cards a month and a
$25 a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy calm /
Pakman